Florida you'd be right next to the
Caribbean islands Venezuela and Brazil
you could visit all of these in a single
day
and if you lived in Nova Scotia Canada
you'd be driving distance from France
England and Germany
although this might sound like fun a lot
of countries would have new neighbors
which could cause some serious issues
for some
places like the United States which used
to have oceans on both sides of the
country would now have Africa on its
East Coast
if these countries didn't get along
things could get ugly
how much easier would it be to start a
war in another country if they were just
a short drive away transporting weapons
people and supplies would all be faster
and cheaper if certain countries were
right next to each other
or none of this would happen and the
entire world would be more unified than
ever with all of us sharing the same
land mass